Hervé
Marseille pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
effectivement hier nous avons écouté ici
en stéréo votre discours lu avec
beaucoup de conviction et de tonicité
par Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie c'est un exercice sacrificiel
auquel nous
compatissons monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez bien fait de venir
aujourd'hui pour préciser les choses
nous avons retenu quand même des phrases
en France tout est possible en le disant
vous pensez à ce qui peut être positif
bien sûr mais malheureusement ça marche
dans les deux sens et la France est
effectivement capable du meilleur mais
aussi de performance moins enviable pour
faire du tout est possible une formule
de confiance et d'espoir nous avons
apprécié votre capacité à aborder tous
les sujets y compris ceux qui fâchent
qui irritent au quotidien ou plus
largement le sentiment d'impuissance de
l'action publique poison de notre
démocratie quant à vos orientations
cardinales dmicardisé dverrouill est
débureaucratisé comment ne pas y
souscrire ces grands axes vous les
mettez au service du réarmement de notre
pays permettez un vieux matou né en
54 de vous proposer un autre terme bien
plus classique mais plus important à mes
yeux celui de justice réarmé est sans
doute nécessaire mais pour une finé
servir la justice car c'est le sentiment
d'injustice et d'iniéquité qui fragilise
aujourd'hui notre société la colère
agricole on vient d'en parler en est la
caricature les agriculteurs sont au
carrefour d'une quadruple injustice
territoriale d'abord opposition accrue
d'un monde qui se sent abandonné
déclassé économique les agriculteurs
sont les parents pauvres du partage de
la de la valeur sociale et culturelle
celle des travailleurs de ceux qui se
lèvent tôt face aux injonctions d'é
Coles blancs hors sol l'injustice de
vivre avec le sentiment de devoir
abandonner ses valeurs enfin justice
injustice face à des normes et des
contraintes françaises ou européennes
qui ne pèsent pas sur leurs concurrents
d'autres pays chez nous l'injustice
commence dès la naissance elle dépend du
milieu mais aussi du lieu où l'on vient
au monde le président de la République
l'a reconnu nous ne garantissons pas
l'égalité de tous les enfants de la
République et pour cause aujourd'hui
naître à la campagne c'est souvent
naître dans un désert médical là réside
sans doute actuellement l'injustice
territoriale la plus insupportable able
or vous l'avez justement souligné nous
ne pouvons pas attendre gentiment que la
fin du numérus closis produise ses
effets régulariser les médecins
étrangers n'y suffira même pas il faudra
avoir le courage et vous venez de le
dire à l'instant d'élargir les
délégations d'acte par
expérimentation plus globalement pour
tâcher de remédier à l'injustice
territoriale le Sénat plaide pour une
décentralisation régénéré qui restitue
des marges aux collectivités qui
insuffle plus d'équité que des égalité
formelle tel est l'esprit de la
différenciation que nous appelons de nos
vux vos mots sont encourageants la
décentralisation n'a pas la place qui
doit lui revenir gageons que vos
propositions permettent d'avancer nous
espérons que votre arrivée signe la fin
de ce rendez-vous manqué avec les
collectivités depuis tant d'années
l'école est aussi un lieu d'injustice
persistante certes on a restreint le
nombre d'élèves par classe dans les
zones prioritaires mais tant reste à
faire bien sûr l'instruction civique
c'est c'est important nous aussi nous
sommes favorables au retour de
l'uniforme mais le véritable enjeu c'est
le retour du mérite de l'excellence du
respect des enseignants pour y parvenir
l'école a besoin d'un CAP clair comme
vous l'avez fortement comme vous l'avez
justement déclaré tout n'est pas
question de moyens il n'y avait pas
besoin d'argent pour abandonner la
méthode globale prenée pendant des
décennies par des idéologues dans cette
France où tout est possible le sentiment
d'injustice habite aussi les classes
moyennes celles qui contribuent sans
recevoir comme vous l'avez dit cela ne
peut plus durer ceci appelle de ma part
deux remarques d'abord les fiscalités de
l'immobilier et des successions sont les
plus mal vécus par les classes moyennes
votre ouverture dans leur direction doit
être l'occasion d'évoluer dans cette
matière ensuite la fraude sociale et
fiscale est au cœur de leur malaise nos
concitoyens méritants ne peuvent plus
supporter de voir d'un côté les
prestations sociales méticuleusement
détournées et de l'autre une poignée
d'entreprise voyou pour échapper à toute
contribution aux charges publiques il
faut mener une guerre sans merci à la
fraude et à l'évasion sous toutes ses
formes l'injustice se vit aussi de plus
en plus dans la question du logement
nous alertons depuis des mois sur la
crise qui vient est désormais présente
vous avez déclaré vouloir la prendre à
bras le corp cependant il n'est pas
certain que la simplification des normes
la réquisition des bâtiment vide ou
l'intégration du logement intermédiaire
dans les critères de la loi et ses rues
suffiront ce sont des mesure pertinentes
qui était attendu mais plusieurs de
centaines de milliers de logements
manquent aujourd'hui comment se dégager
du foncier avec les problèmes du zan en
particulier vous l'avez souligné il
faudra adapter le zan dans son
application tout ne pourra pas reposer
sur la seule densification la transition
écologique soulève également un enjeu
majeur de justice et d'équité car cette
transition aussi vitale et nécessaire
soit-elle va faire des perdants je pense
en particulier au petit propriétaires
qui vont être plombés par le DPE ou aux
artisans que les aidfeu vont empêcher de
travailler Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'injustice se niche jusque dans les
derniers jours de la vie la dépendance
est l'un des défis majeurs qu'il nous
faut relever aujourd'hui avec le
vieillissement de la population c'est
toute la société qui doit se
réinventer nous ne pouvons pourtant plus
procrastiner le modèle social et
financier est au bord de l'implosion
c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir enfin
les inégalités et les injust sont
intergénérationnelles ce qui pose
aujourd'hui la question de la dette et
des déficits s'il nous faut maîtriser la
trajectoire de nos finances publ c'est
bien sûr pour recouvrir des marges de
manœuvre mais c'est aussi pour rétablir
une équité
intergénérationnelle or nous n'en
prenons pas le chemin cette année notre
pays devra emprunter 285 milliards
d'euros c'est plus que le PIB du
Portugal et la charge de la dette devra
bondir de 50 % d'ici à 2027 maîtriser
les dépenses c'est bien sûr faire des
économies mais c'est surtout faire des
réformes de structure sans attendre le
retour des vaches grasses pour terminer
revenons à votre état civil si vous le
permettez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
car nous pouvions attendre d'un jeune
chef du gouvernement qu'il nous ouvre
sur le futur qu'il nous parle
d'intelligence artificielle d'hydrogène
vert d'espace de génétique de ce monde
en transformation pour ne pas dire en
ébullition sur lequel nous devons nous
repositionner on en a pas parler parce
que vous êtes nous sommes rattrapés par
les problèmes du passé que nous n'avons
pas pu résoudre pourtant vous avez
cherché à nous transmettre l'essentiel
l'optimisme et la
détermination comme vous nous savons que
notre avenir sera européen ou ne sera
pas ce qui n'interdit pas d'être
critique vis-à-vis de l'Europe que l'on
a construite trop technocratique et qui
n'est pas celle dont nous rêvions
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous êtes
ici au Sénat et depuis les législatives
de 2022 c'est ici pour l'essentiel qu'on
fabrique les principales lois sans le
Sénat pas de réforme des retraites sans
le Sénat pas de loi
d'immigration dès votre nomination vous
êtes venu à la rencontre du Sénat en
participant à la conférence des
présidents nous avons été sensibles à ce
geste qui constitue un encouragement mes
collègues Bruno rillot et Patrick canner
ont eu l'occasion de vous dire à ce
moment précis que comme nous ils étit
ouvert au dialogue mais hostile à la
coconstruction c'est-à-dire à
l'association des parlementaires à
l'élaboration du projet de loi avant son
dépôt au Parlement car cette méthode lit
les parlementaires sans leur permettre
de véritablement enrichir ou modifier
les textes en revanche nous sommes
favorables à la construction
parlementaire lors de l'examen des
textes c'est la différence entre
coconstruction et construction
d'ailleurs si les textes ont été votés
depuis 2 ans c'est bien parce qu'il y a
eu des compromis des des accords des
constructions qui ont permis d'aboutir
face à notre impuissance nous n'avons
plus les moyens de chercher des
responsables que ce soit le Conseil
constitutionnel Bruxelles les
institutions judiciaires nous devons
supporter 3000 milliards de dettes les
agriculteurs bloquent les routes
l'inflation ronge le pouvoir d'achat la
guerre frappe aux portes de l'Europe
efface peu à peu l'Arménie de la carte
et embrase le ProcheOrient avec l'ombre
inquiétante de l'Iran et le possible
retour de Donald Trump nous pensons que
le dialogue avec le Parlement et
singulièrement avec le Sénat doit être
fertile nous devons nous écouter et nous
devons rechercher les solutions les plus
collectifes possibles alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre cette responsabilité
elle pèse sur vos épaules elle pèse
aussi sur nos épaules si vous échouez si
nous échouons vous et nous savons qui
arbitrera nos différents en 2027 et
alors il sera trop tard pour pleurer sur
le lait renversé je vous
remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est au président